say the men that like are trying to be
women that's why I would say it well
that are trying to be women or
transitioning
I would say I would say trying because
you
it yeah
they can't carry children
okay some biological women have problems
doing that yeah and like like I said
earlier that doesn't make them any less
of a woman yeah some men cannot
impregnate their sperm for whatever
reason has this but the difference is
trans people can never do it that's fine
that's fine how many people how many
heterosexual people have had children
I'm pretty sure every single transition
I'm pretty sure every single transgender
person on the planet was born from a
heterosexual man and woman just because
someone is born man and born a woman it
doesn't give them the right to be
parents don't